what's happening there reject nation we
are
back at it to learn more about the
excitement
of the flashpoint movie which is batman
that's the exciting part about flash
it's always the exciting part of any of
these dc
just very curious to see how this all
pans out nostalgically i'm sure
yes i'm still excited though it's
michael keaton you know
there's a lot to look forward to
cinematic flash point
i mean you won't care if you've never
watched those first two batman movies
[Music]
very very i just found out i'm pregnant
and it's mine of course it's yours silly
no i knew
look at that onto my backdrop it would
become relevant
and boy today i love the new set man it
looks great
we talked about today guys is andy
muschetti the director of the upcoming
flash movie went ahead and posted the
first teaser of the new bat suit
michael keaton will be wearing in the
flash movie and while at first glance it
might seem like an old batsuit when you
look at some details it's a new
upgraded suit and it's got some blood on
it we're gonna be talking about that and
breaking that down right here but i'm
gonna need your guys opinions down below
what do you think of this photo of the
bad suit does it get you excited to see
michael keaton again
i know there's a lot of other younger
people out there who don't care at all
that michael keaton's coming back
because it's just past their time and
maybe christian bale is more of like
their batman so go ahead and leave your
thoughts down below on what you think
about some people
on his instagram page this is it right
here our first book of the michael
keaton batsu
and just to remind you guys this flash
movie deals with barry allen
traveling into the multiverse where he's
going to be exploring
different avenues of the dc universe
we're going to have two batman's in this
movie ben affleck
and michael keaton where barry will be
spending most of his adventure with
michael keaton's batman he's also going
to meet
latina super girl that's already been
left tina's super
bunch clear surprise dc characters
popping up but me as a batman fan and a
lover of michael keaton i have been
waiting to see what his new suit is
so rugged and worn in his likes
and dust yeah mark's all over what does
his new suit look like and at first
glance
i was slightly disappointed even though
i was really excited because
if you're a watcher of those michael
keaton batman movies it's pretty obvious
to tell
that this is inspired by the batman
right the burn suit okay
and the way it makes that weird angle at
the bottom and also the bad symbol
is different than the bad symbol in the
very first batman movie with michael
keaton so i was kind of puzzled like oh
my they're gonna give him the exact same
bad suit and that's what he's been
wearing but yeah i mean he's been
wearing this a long time but it doesn't
look
polished at all no it looks like rugged
it looks like battle
he's bruce wayne yeah he has the
capability of
you know being able to call upon an
alfred or hire anyone
could do it too even looking at the
batman returns one look how like slick
and clean and tim burton
pretty it is this one is like scratchy
it looks like pretty much every item
i've
ever owned in my entire life i
eventually just don't take care of it
people are telling me to throw it out
i'm like no it's nostalgic
i want it i want to keep it i like it
there's a gritty feel about it that
looks like a jelly doughnut
yeah actually he was just eating a donut
and he never cleaned it that's a 20 year
old jelly stain
this is robin's last donut i can't bring
myself to wash it out
michael keaton's batman was dark it
looks like they're going to be amping up
just how much
darker it is yeah now he he breaks
people's noses
yeah he doesn't feel killed
let's see what else chris has to say
though for decades upon decades a true
batman would upgrade as he goes and heck
from one movie to the next michael
keaton's batman did upgrade
but upon closer inspection and bringing
in the batman return suit
you see some big differences that lets
you know oh this is an
upgraded version and totally different
than what we've seen really
one thing i'm loving about this upgraded
suit though is that they are keeping
that yellow emblem right there i just
think that's so iconic with batman
and so classic with the character but a
lot of the batman's that we have
nowadays just get rid of that yellow
because it sticks out they're supposed
to be incognito not this bad man he no
care but the symbol here on his chest is
a little bit more of a 3d effect it's
puffed out the yellow seems also a
little bit darker the chest
part still seems to be the same but one
of the big differences looks like you
can remove it
on this new bat suit is the part of
where i imagine the cow
next to the bat symbol if you look at
the old batman return suit
it was a cape that was connected all the
way around halfway into that symbol
not having those lines at all and maybe
it's just me but i feel like this has
more of a metallic finish like this
feels
metal where the batman returns to i see
the more plasticness but that could just
be because it's an old suit maybe they
were going for a metallic look so we can
definitely
expect this to be an upgraded batman
suit that is still
in line with what tim burton was doing
in his batman universe that's exciting
we can't miss the elephant in the room
is why is there blood on the batman suit
i mean i think that's cool that we got
blood on the batman suit because of the
fact that i didn't know if
michael keaton would actually don the
batman suit this is more of an indicator
that at one point he will and even get
into a fight scene i thought it might
just be like old man
mentor bruce wayne or something like
that well yeah i mean and and
to speak to that you know this image of
the symbol but
with the blood then at least to me hints
like okay this is gonna be your harder
battle rugged bruce wayne as well you
know maybe something
more frank miller everyone wants to get
to the dark knight returns that's where
everyone's trying to get to
make it happen as soon as possible flash
pointed whatever
i mean if he is this kind of like
brutality version of batman
it would be a little bit like the thomas
wayne one from flashpoint so it works
guys that's not look man was having a pb
j sandwich okay guys got to eat
that little touch of blood it was
actually really cool and should kind of
let you know what some of the stuff
we're going to be seeing
in this universe don't forget andy
muschetti comes from a horror background
the guy
directed it chapter one and in chapter
two so there's probably a reason warner
brothers was like
um we are kind of wanting to go a little
scary with this one or darker
let's bring in a hard director i don't
think it's the case at all
let me know this batman's gonna get his
butt whooped here and there and
probably as he should because the man is
old and while he's wiser
he probably can't fight the way he used
to but then again i would hope if he'd
still make him the big buck kicking
batman michael king should be because i
just imagine that's what he would become
and he got to be able to turn his head
too
yep yeah upgrade his head safety
yeah i got it right we got a really
quick and machete i don't think he's
brought on board for the horror at all i
mean i
even brought james juan on board for
aquaman he didn't do any horror in that
like there was like a hints of horde
like a couple of scenes out of like a
two
plus hour movie but it's not for the
horror scott derrickson for a doctor
strange one are there some tense
spooky sure but it's not a horror at
all in terms of the genre of the film
this is supposed to be like a
nightmarish scenario for
the flash obviously this is supposed to
be a nightmare situation for the guy to
be in
not really getting the vibe that they're
gonna hone in on that it would be
cool i would love to be totally wrong on
this i would love to be wrong on this
uh but i i'm not getting the impression
that that's the case yeah i feel like
they'll bring an emotional sense of
intensity
but i don't expect any real horror vibes
especially because like yeah they had a
horror
spin off and they canceled it like it
doesn't seem like that's their vibe
right now
any experienced batman is an ultimate
batman it also probably goes without
saying he'll probably get another bad
suit by the end of the movie especially
if this suit does resemble a little too
much of the batman return suit
you know they're going to upgrade him
for some reason just because that's what
they like to do in superhero movies for
merchandising purposes
i wonder if the cow is still going to be
the thing where he can only turn his
head one way with his whole damn body
was also iconic with michael keaton's
batman but dc right now is just showing
off their suits like crazy
wanting to tease people i mean we got
the new shazam suit yesterday i did a
video on that you know we're going to be
getting
the new flash shoot soon they're going
to be showing us the black adam suit
soon
a lot of suits coming your way so i hope
you like costumes but i want to hear
from you guys out there what do you
think of this little tease for andy
muschetti's the flash movie with this
batman suit
what would you like to see done in it do
you like the feel they're going for
right now
what if it does end up turning out to be
just a tiny tweak version of the return
suit will that be kind of disappointing
cause man's been batman for so long what
do you think he'd be all high-tech and
buffed out by now but
maybe he is and everything be sure to
leave your thoughts down below don't
forget to like subscribe
follow me on twitter f3c film review as
always i'm chris
take care it's only the symbol
it's only the centerpiece we gotta see
the rest of the studio yeah it's hard to
comment on the gadgets and all that
because we don't know
we just don't know the rest of it is
purple how funny would that be
it just really made it rainbow colors
it's all bright and vibrant in order to
keep the joker buried i had to become
the jury
and now i find myself on the streets of
gotham every night
i'm looking forward to it though i think
dc phantom will get an actual trailer
but in the meantime these little hints
and teases are pretty cool
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button and more
importantly
subscribe to chris from 3c films if you
haven't done so already
guy is uh he's blowing up like a mother
effer
for a reason anyhoo
anissa oliva this one's easy because a
anissa i want to hop on a call
with you i've got some things to talk
with you about very personal things
very personal things that i will make
public hoping we can get views
off of the drama of our phone call but
more importantly you sent me this shirt
and i love this shirt and i've been
waiting for the right shirt
wait yep yeah no that's right i ready
for the right video to wear this shirt
and i was like well if we're doing a
flash video that's about the batman
symbol specifically focusing on the
symbol had to go
with the traditional one right here and
that's next to you of course it's got
like this beautiful neon
neon look to it yeah i like it thank you
so much anisa for everything you still
message
me like little tips here and there
things to check out and a conversation
is long overdue
it's time to invite you in the bedroom
oh john's bedroom
that's right we're done out of the gas
[Music]
station